nous sommes aujourd'hui dans le cher à
vos goûts plus exactement dans sa forêt
un petit village de 700 habitants et
c'est le club de spéléologie locale qui
nous emmène découvrir la richesse de ses
terres plus connu pour le vin que pour
ce qu'elle cache une balade un peu
sportive réalisé avec louis claveau
lawrence bories et laurent vori la
spéléologie reste une activité physique
et un minimum d'équipement est
nécessaire pour assurer la sécurité
équipés de baudriers mousquetons casque
lumière l'excursion peut commencer
d'accord et donc c'est par là qu'on doit
passer oui c'est l'entrée de la grotte
des nattes entraînements
c'est qui ça s'appelle une étroiture
pour entrer dans les grottes
effectivement le plafond n'est pas très
hauts de seine sur quatre pattes et
après seulement quelques mètres sous
terre
déjà une première rencontre au sportif
quand vous avez des araignées des
chauves-souris et plein de petit
invertébré aussi bon on continue
allons-y
[Musique]
et donc là dans la partie initiation on
découvre qu'il ya des stalactites ici
vous en avez plein de représenter ici
alors les stalactites se forment par là
l'eau de pluie qui va s'infiltrer dans
le sol par des failles et on va
retrouver l'eau chargée de calcaire qui
vont se déposer dans la grotte sur le
plafond pour fermer des stalactites et
là on voit les stalactites sont plutôt
petits font un centimètre en centimètres
et demi et ont ils ont quel âge avait un
bon centimètre ça représente ici une
centaine d'années lorsque l'on descend
encore plus sous la roche les pierres
nous délivre alors d'autres mystères
historique et géologiques donc la france
y sont nés à l étage inférieur il ya
encore plein d'autres choses à voir
assure sur les murs incrusté dans les
murs oui on voit effectivement des
fossiles d'ici là et en fait ce sont des
coquillages des bivalves ces fossiles
ont l'âge de la couche qui les contient
celle oxfordien environ 160 à 157
millions d'années et on se rend compte
et des inscriptions sur le mur là on est
sur ce pilier écrit trompa le nom du
carrier qui a travaillé ici et en bas
1844 donc la date de ce monsieur
travailler et probablement l'ouverture
de la carrière
et je suis avec patrick le président du
club de spéléologie de veaugues alors
patrick on l'a vu cette activité est
ouverte à presque tout le monde
oui tout à fait ouvert à tous juste
avoir un peu
de faire un peu de sport d'être souple
mais très facile
d'accès et bien entendu accompagné par
le club local et donc lors de ses
visites
on peut découvrir plein de choses il ya
plein de choses ludiques à faire et à
voir dans ces grottes
oui on a aménagé dans cette cavité tout
un parcours pour l'initiation on observe
en même temps tout toute la vie
cavernicoles qu'on peut y trouver les
insectes les chauves-souris et aussi
tout ce qui est en relation avec les
concrétions et dans le sancerrois on est
sur des calcaires crieu qui sont
propices aux grottes naturelles
d'encenser roi des calcaires créés yeux
c'est à dire calcaire friable très
friable qui ont servi ces calcaire à la
construction des maisons locales et de
la cathédrale de bourges et on trouve
ces grottes principalement dans le
sancerrois y en a d'autres dans la
région
il y en a des carrières à peu près dans
tout le département du cher et beaucoup
surtout à bourges la particularité
avocat c'est que dans ces anciennes
carrières
on a découvert des avens naturelles qui
ont été découvertes à l'époque par les
carriers qui ont creusé ces carrières
merci pour ces explications et bien
quant à nous nous nous retrouvons demain
pour une nouvelle visite du patrimoine
souterrain en région centre val de loire